kyle is with us in columbus ohio hi kyle
what's up
hey guys how are you doing better than
we deserve how can we help
hey so uh i just wanted to get your
advice uh what a situation um
my my wife and i um are on baby step two
we love you guys we're kind of new the
last couple months we're on baby step
two
um and my wife will be graduating in the
spring with her
master's degree um right now our
household income is about
113 000 and her salary stands to double
once she's graduated grad school
so my question um and that will put your
information
about 163 000. what's she getting her
masters in
so it's a it's an advanced healthcare
degree right now it's a new degree but
it's equivalent to like a nurse
practitioner or a
physician's assistant basically she'll
be able to function like a pulmonary
fellow
um and yeah it's absolutely amazing
um so my question is we've had some
issues in the past with my
mother-in-law specifically um as i've
heard you say she probably is kind of a
travel agent for guilt trips
um and to where
she and my sisters-in-laws have reached
out to my wife for
financial help in the past for certain
things um so my question with that
is kind of as my wife is approaching
this this point in
um on in our life in our marriage and in
her career
where she will be making more money how
do i
help support her moving forward
when i i know in the back of my mind
my in-laws will probably just be asking
for more
and more as she makes more money in her
career
does she want to give them that money um
she wants to help them but she doesn't
want to enable them
she she's she's been burned in the past
um to the point where
now i'm concerned for her emotional and
mental health
she's she's been so bad she's had two
panic attacks in the past
yeah so she she has in the past but in
the last year or so she's made the
decision to
um basically cut them off unless it's
you know an absolute
emergency here's the thing um
my daughters were teenagers we spent a
lot of time discussing
uh pre-marital sex
because if you wait until you're he the
moment to decide about that
you're gonna lose the decision and so
you have to decide
ahead of time and steal
your mind s-t-e-e-l
your mind to be ready for
an an inevitable conflict
and you have to have already decided
before the conflict occurs what's going
to happen
and you have to build up the courage and
the muscle
in your brain to be ready for that and
so
i i think that's what you're asking and
i think that's what you've got to do and
it may involve seeing a counselor it may
involve you
you guys sitting down with her pastor
and releasing her
from her felt obligation to these people
to where she really gets
very comfortable with no okay
i don't know john yeah and the challenge
you're going to have is you're going to
want to
do that no for her oh and until she
won't work till she comes to
comes to terms with her ability to tell
her family no
um you're just gonna have to play a
supporting role there you can as we
talked about earlier you can cause a
ruckus man you can say
yeah i don't want using our money it's
hurting them
but that's this is her family and this
is a brilliant
woman your wife she's getting a master's
degree in the healthcare field
she's not lacking an intellect apply
that
intellect to growing walking you walking
with her have her apply that intellect
to growing
in this area of emotional strength
and she loves her pulmonary patients
enough to say stop
smoking don't go run after you just had
this she needs to love her family in
that same way
and say no right yep
yep absolutely and it's very
difficult the most difficult boundary
setting
is between a daughter and a mother a
daughter and her sister
female to female is the most difficult
guys can look at each other and go
screw you no a lot easier
it's a lot easier for us right yeah i
mean we just
because we're just combative but for
ladies it's like the emotional
relational thing is like oh my god you
know i heard their feelings and it's
like
you know but she's going to reach a
point where she's going to end the
relationship completely if she doesn't
deal with this
in strength ahead of time now and it's
going to get nasty
the earlier she can draw boundaries the
better
yeah and just tell her to get ready for
the next time but go ahead and start
working on it
spend some you know like you study you
know get i'm going to send you
uh a copy of uh dr dolany's book
redefining anxiety i'm also going to
send you a copy of dr henry cloud's book
boundaries
and this is her homework she's got to
get ready
for because what happens is the when you
set a boundary with someone who doesn't
have boundaries
100 of the time they come at you they
want to know if that boundary is going
to hold right
well they feel entitled to you right
they feel entitled to a chunk of your
butt
and they keep chewing on your butt until
you don't have one
and they will chew your after they shoot
your butt off they'll chew your soul out
from under you
yep that's exactly what happens you're
gonna let your family starve you
hate your mother what's wrong you don't
after all i've done for you
you're just gonna let your sister she
just needs all i've that this is your
own
flesh and blood i don't know what we did
you oh
oh cause you're fancy now you got your
master's your fans oh
yeah you done you done gone up above
your raisins you don't know you don't
you forgot where you came from
no i didn't and that's why i'm not there
that's right i don't forget a bit of it
kyle you're a good man stand by that
woman